how many pitch meetings will an
executive usually have in one day cuz
we're going in we're ten minutes early
we've got our most you know business
casual I don't know what we're wearing
but something that makes us feel
comfortable but missus look good we're
ready this is the biggest deal but this
person's already met with how many
people okay
when I was at CBS and comedy development
we would meet with people at ten o'clock
eleven o'clock twelve o'clock three
o'clock four o'clock and five o'clock
Wow six so here's a tip get the early
morning meeting do not get a late
afternoon especially don't get a late
afternoon meeting on Fridays if you can
get a morning meeting that's the best
way to do it
executives are experienced at taking
meetings they know how to do that so if
you have to get an afternoon when that
doesn't it's it's not it's not going to
sink you but your pitch has to be great
if your pitch is great then they'll come
alive because they're looking for great
pitches because it makes their job
easier so if if you have an engaging
pitch they'll come alive if the pitch is
boring in the late afternoon it's harder
to pay attention to it okay let's talk
about working on your pitch because
again we see ourselves one way other see
us either are we coming up with a script
for our pitch or is it better to be
spontaneous don't be spontaneous it
should be rehearsed it's a performance
it shouldn't be memorized to within an
inch of its life
that's not a good idea you should know
it backwards and forwards and sideways
and then put away the paper although you
can have notes if you want and then make
it a conversation do not leave it to I'm
just going to walk in and do this no
this is it's like people in school you
want to be an overachiever be completely
prepared not memorize
but completely prepared I have a former
mentee who's sold a lot of pilots its
pilot scripts she never goes in unless
she's practiced eight times
she practices eight times she practiced
sit in front of people she practices in
front of a mirror
she practices and practices and there
was a writer producer who was phenomenal
named Stephen camel he was the most
prolific television creator and producer
in the business he was always practicing
his pitch
I knew his daughter and she said you
know we couldn't go to the store without
him pitching and if he was walking down
the hallway in his building he would
buttonhole you and come and tell you the
pitch and ask for feedback practice
practice practice
you